hello youtubers up next is my exclusive
interview
with actor zachary quinto
[Music]
this is star talk i'm neil degrasse
tyson your personal
astrophysicist and i've got with me
chuck nice co-hosting that's right
all right and tweeting at chuck nice
comic thank you i follow you
i follow you too okay to the ends of the
earth
and beyond to the gates of hell in the
trenches
uh and i've got
chuck glue i can't call you chuckles
he's chuck charles lou
you can call me whatever you no i'm not
calling i just said i'm not okay okay
okay charles liu uh professor of
astronomy and physics at uh
college of staten island yes city
university of new york yes and
our fan base knows that if you
are my guest on a show yes we're going
to get geek that's oh right
okay we're going to roll out some geckos
all right we're preaching my interview
with actors
zachary quinto you know zachary quinto
yes
that's mr spock he's mr spock yes he's
like the next generation
rendering of the iconic
hyper rational character from the
original star trek series
he is the actor with the highest scoring
name
in scrabble wow
okay why do you know that
wait so he got a z and you got the q
he's got his playing on the triple word
score you are
all set i mean if you spell his whole
name out spell his whole name
a z and a q and a okay we've got some
a's in there they're they're not that's
what they're saying c is three the h is
four and the y
is four the rest of them are ones there
you go
idiot
[Laughter]
there you have it no zachary's been my
hero in part
because of that extremely extreme name
i would bet he would want to be your
hero for reasons beyond that
but so we're going to explore the
science
of science fiction excellent we're using
him as an excuse to do that excellent
and there's no better excuse
for that because he's a hyper logical
alien yes
he's a vulcan fascinating
half hypological alien oh that's right
because he's got a half human
mammy that's right he got a mama he got
human mammy right
and couldn't resist that the lore of
those earth women because earth girls
are easy
that was what's his face um uh it's
downtown julie brown no
no no no earth girls are easy yeah
that's what was
it was this was it weird al yankovic no
no no no no
you know i'm the fly i'm the becca i'm
the fly i'm the fly brother fly
just deaf gold blue blue was in the
movie earth girls are easy that's right
right but the song earth girls are easy
formed by someone named julie brown who
also did
um trapped in the body of a white girl
and everybody run the homecoming queens
got a gun
wow nice i mean i don't know
any of the thing you just said but they
said it but you said it was such an
authority
you know homecoming queens got a gun no
or oh i don't know this song i kind of
remember from the 80s i did it
for johnny is it from the 80s it's from
the eighth yeah okay
now got me all right all right it sounds
like george of the jungles
so he's got you know as all good actors
do they they have an acting pedigree
that that extends back uh he's trained
in classical theater
excellent and i asked him about the
transition from this
formal background into science fiction
in both film and television so let's
check it out
i mean there is something inherently
theatrical about science fiction which i
find interesting you know the world of
star trek i think is
is shakespearean in a way if you really
break it down and and the
the canon of stories and the the lineage
that
overlaps itself um i think is really
theatrical
and and so much is happening on
television now that
the landscape is entirely different than
it was even five years ago it's amazing
we can all agree
it's a golden age of television yeah and
the challenge now i think is really
uh you know grabbing people's attention
and then holding people's attention
because as there are more and more
what are you talking about uh there are
more and more platforms
you know it's just like that how do we
how do we get people and
and direct them in the right way it's
interesting it's an interesting
double-edged sword in a way so charles
what
explain what he means by star trek being
shakespearean because
i followed a little bit but i think you
would have a deeper insight how is star
trek like shakespeare
let me count the ways oh the world's a
stage
come in and women let me just
look let me just quote christopher
plummer in star trek six the
undiscovered country playing general
chang the klingon
to be or not to be
yes in klingons the klingons
all thought that shakespeare was written
originally
in their language those idiots
no because of the rhythms or the rhythms
the the
human klingon condition the whole point
of shakespeare is that
his body of work demonstrates all the
different
highs and lows and in comedies and
tragedies
of the human condition of life of
society of individuals interacting with
the whole
and so there's a universal truth to it
that transcends
any culture if it's properly translated
klingons
romulans humans and for the first time
you've used the phrase
universal truth in a literal meaning yes
most people when they say universe
universe they're talking about earth
yeah like miss universe
it's just miserable right you know we
didn't compare it with missing mars
right no they ain't how that happened
yeah so the office atari wasn't here
shakespeare appears over and over again
throughout star trek
on purpose and sort of accidentally just
as it does on just about every other
major science fiction
space opera type but wait a minute
shakespeare
wrote about practically everything yes
in many different ways
so for it to have a story and say it's
shakespearean
can't you say that about every story as
long as jerry is shakespeare
i mean maybe but the what we're talking
about because if it fits everything then
it fits nothing
oh if it fits everything it fits
everything it also fits nothing
the point is [ __ ]
chew on that one yeah okay shakespeare
really told the story of tom and jerry
better is that the difference that's why
shakespeare is so involved right
just even star trek six the movie i just
quoted the
subtitle is the undiscovered country
right which is
hamlet right as is to be or not to be
now in the movie the chancellor of the
klingons
said that the undiscovered country was
the future but of course in hamlet's
soliloquy
the undiscovered country was death and
so
that became a theme in that movie where
do klingons really fear death or do they
fear
the unknown the future i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna go with the unknown
exactly because they definitely want to
die a glorious
death imbalance exactly which is what
caused a
central tension in that movie and the
plot and so forth
and then the evil well i don't want to
say evil
but the general chang to which i
referred as in the
as he was fighting the final battle
against kirk he was
quoting shakespeare over and over again
cry havoc and let's slip the dogs of war
from julius caesar correct you know all
these other kinds of fighting things and
then
and that's why he lost that's why he
lost the balance i actually saw
christopher plummer
on broadway with lynn redgrave in hamlet
and um not hamlet um yes right
yeah macbeth so he imagined the joy
that the actor christopher plummer must
have had in full cling on armor
fighting a space battle saying as his
final words before his ship explodes
to be or not to be
nice shakespeare and star trek hmm
wow that was quite the trek in itself
man
dude wow chuck god
stop calling chuck cause i don't know
who you thought you were talking to
yourself charles
please feel free call me chuck charles
thank you for that recitation
for that just one piece of it see what i
did there
you see what i did there the last poor
neil i knew him well horatio
a host of infinite chest the fault
dear charles is not in your stars
but in yourself all right then
nice job out out brief candle and by
that i mean this conversation no it's
okay
or poor player that struts and frets his
hour on the stage and is heard no more
it is a tale told by an
idiot full of
we
so am i i don't know how you get back
how i can get back in this conversation
all right
so uh before zachary quinto was spock
he was silar yes on heroes
on the super villain in abc's hit
science five series heroes
yes that's the one that no one
understood correct oh it was great for
the first season then it jumped the
shark
oh really yeah that early not supposed
to jump to shark well they
kept they kept like changing everything
let's see what he says about it yeah
okay zachary quinto on heroes check it
out you had the power
to take people's power yeah right yeah
that's badass i stole people's powers i
was sort of omnipowerful
that's bad but i had to murder them
viciously in order to get those powers
oh so there was that that little caveat
but uh remind me did you have a
a baseball heel no no oh an achilles
heel
interestingly i did have an achilles
heel
but but they kept changing it like i was
invincible
unless they killed me in this one way
and then as the show went on and they
wanted to keep the character around they
kept changing it so
part of the deflation of the
role and i think ultimately the series
was they had you know they had to keep
changing their own rules and so
audiences felt a little bit like they
didn't know what to invest in
and that's the nature of having to keep
a successful show going for so long you
know so that show went four seasons so
it's like a hundred episodes of just
trying to sustain these characters many
of whom probably should have died
last season for the in order to keep the
story going but
it was also a different characters
shouldn't needed my character should
have too i think
it was like a it was like a um it was a
trap of the success of that show
and i must confess uh my original urge
to watch it was because the oh in heroes
was a
total eclipse i get it yeah that was my
that was the only reason why i
first watched the show
charles why is it important to not break
rules when you're storytelling
any narrative has to be within a context
at least the literary what i mean it has
to be if you just because they have been
doesn't mean it has to be
you can do post-modern literature where
the rules keep getting broken all the
time but then you know that the rule is
that the rules are meant to be broken
when you're telling a narrative an epic
an opera a story
or something like that if you are
invested in a character or storyline
and then it no longer has significance
that's not cool like if you love a
character and the character dies
has significance but then if you find
out that any character can be
risen from the dead merely by giving an
injection of somebody's blood
defense death means nothing and then
what you cared about
isn't important anymore if you knew at
the very beginning of the story that
anyone who dies can come back to life
fine but if you find that out in season
two so what you're saying is this
they're kind of making this stuff up
yeah they were
wrong i don't think they expected it to
go past one season
but it was a great story in part because
of great actors like zachary
um he played this this watchmaker
okay siler wasn't even his real name
sila was the name of a watch that he was
working on when his power manifested
and he was really what you could you
could call you know hana rent's
idea of the banality of evil somebody
who
you wouldn't think is like vicious and
likely to kill anybody but just present
it with a circumstance he was a
watchmaker he cared about details
and then all of a sudden he opened up
somebody's brain and figured out that
person's superpower
and then went on and on and on until it
became this addiction where he slipped
down that slope
because yeah because he was a psychopath
that's really the deal the word for that
yeah
you know and and one of the things that
was borne out in the show was
was he a psychopath and then this power
showed up
or did he become a psychopath because of
his powers there was an
alternative interesting duality yes
exactly
there was an alternate timeline in that
show where it showed
seiler not calling himself siler but
gabriel
he had adopted a young person and
actually had become a hero
been a good person but then was
not able to sustain that because of the
pressure okay so what shows have kept to
their own rules best would you say
well star trek does pretty well although
although although although each episode
in the original season
where spock did something where he
almost died or went blind
but then there was an extra eyelid that
prevented him from going blind well
and and and bones said i should have
i should have known you'd come up with
something like that
right so they even knew in the script
that they had to sort of say something
about that right
because you didn't know in advance that
he had a special eyelid right right that
prevented from going
concept of retconning right retractive
continuity
is allowable when you have these huge
kind of sprawling stories
but you still have to every time explain
what was going on
star wars for example not so good
the kessel run don't get me started on
the question yeah no i know
no no skip that on the same page because
i will i will blow a gasket okay i know
and then they had to be clear for people
to know
when he says the middle and falcon did
the castle run in under 12 parsecs
right that's like saying uh you know
if i say chuck how much do you weigh you
so i weigh 3.50 cents
how fast are you driving the car 72
degrees fahrenheit
different units it's complete idiots
okay but in the movie solo no they don't
they double down on i don't want to hear
about double down by
retconning the whole process they
retroactively that messed up a lot of
people it makes people unhappy
yeah like me right and that's why you
can't go back and mess with things
that's too much
so he went from super villain to i don't
call him super
hero but super alien spock yes in
the star trek the reboot of the star
tech films yes so let's just get a
snippet of him
reflecting on becoming spock check it
out
it's one of the most recognizable
characters in the world
i mean up there with mickey mouse and
jesus i mean it's it
in in terms of like the iconography of
spock and the
um the visual um familiarity that people
have with that character and
his ears and his gestures and all of
that so i guess there was that
kind of floating around me and i didn't
allow myself to get swept away
in any of the things that are attached
to that role
why because it would have protected yeah
i mean i couldn't have done my job
i think if i had allowed myself to go
with the magnitude of who that character
is and what he represents to so many
people for so long
i just had to focus on what was right in
front of me
you know leonard was involved at that
time uh and i got to
i mean leonard and i became incredibly
close to that process so it was a
creative and professional
um gift but also a tremendous personal
gift to
to become so close with leonard as well
who is the who
leonard leonard leonard nimoy so the the
original
actor portraying spock was his mentor
it sounded like in this in this bit so
can you
charles explain why spock was such an
accounted character
well first of all
spock as a character was the first alien
that really had a prominent role in any
television or movie show that lasted and
showed that had characterization so he
was fascinating because he was other
and yet similar to us but more important
in my opinion
it was the brilliant acting of leonard
nimoy that made spock so iconic
he
and the ideas that made it happen uh
there are television critics historians
for example who will talk about
uh kirk played by william shatner
becoming
increasingly emotional increasingly
melodramatic as the series went on
and what spock leonard nimoy did was
simply become that foil
become even more less emotional even
more detached even more logical
and then they canceled the show it
created
that balance which then led to that rich
idea of
yin and yang equilibrium you know kirk
and spock becoming that
scene of the pants versus total logic
and then they play chess
right and kirk wins every time because
he's not making logical moves
right which i never got no no totally if
yeah i once played
the first time i beat a computer at
chess i only was able to do that
fooling it into thinking i was making
one move relative to another and it
would
organize all of its peace strategies
thinking i'm going to make a move
and i don't came in the back side and
then
but that's how we play chess anyway we
always try to fool our opponent
right whether it's a computer or a human
being yeah okay so
okay thank you no thank you well done
thank you that's old days
right the first time i beat a computer
is in the future
of another timeline in another universe
you know exactly
all right uh we gotta take a break and
we will talk
more about emotion versus logic in the
next segment from star trek returns
we're back on star talk featuring my
interview with zachary quinto
actor yes modern day is best known for
playing
young spock they look just like what
spock wouldn't look like
he really does that's what kind of
helped him that's some serious casting
they did there and it's not even young
spock it's different timeline
spock right that's right yeah about that
and so i had to ask
him about spock's
notorious reliance on logic
over emotion sweet it's good it's
interesting to get an actor's take on
that let's check it out
there's these two parts of spock um
his human essence and his vulcan essence
and i think that
i can relate to that i process
things uh in an intellectual way
personally
um and emotion is always underneath that
right so i feel like
uh i don't i don't i don't always go to
intellect first but i definitely lean
toward intellect
and then emotion is surrounding it and
under it
oh so it's not in the center of it no i
don't think so that means you make
rational decisions in science it's
pretty rational how do people
make emotions yeah i definitely have an
ability to separate my emotional
response
from my um rational
or uh intellectual response a little bit
yeah oh
okay interesting so he's he's feeling
the character i was gonna say yeah he
thinks he's spock
zachary okay he just got out of therapy
so charles tell me about your irrational
and emotional minds you know i've
thought about this before
and i've come to the conclusion i
believe that my emotional reactions
and my logical reactions are knit
together
as tightly as a tapestry a flannel
pattern
i can't separate the two of them very
well at all so you're very
logically emotional or emotionally or
emotionally less
so i can reason out things but i'm
always informed by my
own feelings and i can always feel about
something but i always think about wait
why am i feeling this how am i feeling
this
and it's all knit together and i
actually don't want to separate them i
think that's what makes me
like the human i am possibly human yes
right which is one of the things that
was explored in in the star trek
universe vulcans actually have very
strong emotions right
but society compels them to suppress
emotion
and only exhibit logic right and this is
what
makes it very difficult for them
tremendously powerful
but also an achilles heel i i can
i can separate it pretty well i you know
start star trek spock
his logical approach life is almost
always at odds with captain kirk's yes
of course
and so i asked zachary about
that dynamic on screen let's check it
out
kirk and spock are probably one of the
most iconic duos
um in popular culture history who would
you rather be
obviously spot obviously because you're
still playing the role
yeah come on now um you can you can tell
me
no one will know except for people there
you definitely feel
like they are inextricably connected on
a spiritual level
um they're two sides of the same coin i
think as roddenberry envisioned these
characters they represent
an exploration and examination of what
it means to be human and what it means
to be
alien and how those two parts of
ourselves
as people you know are often
in proximity and often in conflict
spock and kirk function very differently
but i don't think either would function
as effectively without the other one
so chuck would you rather be
kirk or spock oh that's a really hard
question and here's why mr spock
so logical so methodical so meticulous
and so knowledgeable i mean you know the
vulcan brain is
like you know he is a human computer um
able to calculate you out of your
[ __ ] mind
[Laughter]
one of the lines yeah i love it but um
i i so for all those reasons i want to
be spock
however kirk i want to sleep with a
green woman man
that's all right i'm just not going to
laugh yeah yeah so
not getting any intergalactic spock does
not except for like once every 10 years
he has to go cali feed cauliflower or
some old crap where he gets far he goes
in the heat then he goes into
vulcan heat and you know and then he
still doesn't get any
you know it's like you know i don't know
finger tips remember
yes okay so it's going to be yeah i'm
going i'm going with curls
i'm going i'm going with kirk
so get your green balls so charles this
thing about yin and yang
yes and comment on that well
obviously life is an equilibrium
you and i we are all here and doing what
we're doing today because there's a
balance between the energy
that's going through our bodies coming
out of them and
whatever is being put into them like
food or metabolism and so on so forth
also there are three evil versions of
ourself in another universe
we'll get to that and one of them
there's a chuck in another universe with
a goatee
wait you have a goatee here you're the
evil child
yeah oh my god give us the good job the
universe you saw you've called me evil
chuck before and somebody on twitter
said
from now on you're chuck rude
anyway my point is that if we are to
explore life itself then we are thinking
both spiritually and
physically psychologically about balance
about
an extreme that needs to be balanced and
so things moving forward and around
is what causes us to have all these
different cool things happen
fiction is fundamentally about society
coming out of balance and what happens
to bring it back right but balance
implies that it's teetering on falling
in one direction or another
whereas you can have balance without
that a marble on a flat
surface is balanced right all right but
you wouldn't say there's a yin and yang
operating on yeah because that's a meta
stability
right that we call that as physicists
you know that so
imagine instead the marble in a dip
in a valley and then once in a while
something pushes
the marble up the hill a little bit okay
and of course where there's restoring
it's a restoring force it
brings it back down into the equilibrium
point down below
when you have something that's
metastable like a table and you're
rolling the marble
it keeps going and then it falls off the
table that's not life
that becomes something more extreme
which can be studied but it's not
that would be the end of life one
example
right interesting okay that was a little
philosophical i liked it yeah i still
like it
no i i i i would quibble with something
you said oh dear
okay life by its very nature
are centers of highly
disequilibrium phenomena i see what
you're saying
yes because we are examples of the local
thermodynamic equilibrium being violated
violated correct
because we are forced to your body
temperature is 98 degrees
out of freaking equilibrium dude but i
am out of equilibrium with my
surroundings
yes within myself i have to be 98.6
plus or minus a degree or two at all
times or i stop living
okay so okay so that therapy told me
within myself
i'm i am at peace i'm glad it's doing
something
with the rest of the universe right
another disequilibrium part is
we inhale oxygen it oxygenates the iron
the iron then goes through and it
deposits the oxygen in our muscles
and comes back without oxygen so in our
same body
we have reduced and oxygenated iron
living in the same vessel and in
in the in in nature you don't see that
either all the iron is oxidized all the
iron is not oxidized that's because of
an equilibrium process
because we're not in equilibrium that's
what i'm saying that we are able to
maintain that
that's what i'm saying very cool that's
all i'm saying well said
okay well so when when i can't believe
we just got there from
freaking spock okay so that was amazing
so when the star trek the original star
trek franchise was rebooted
i was in 2009 they kept all the
characters
yes okay and got actors to look like the
characters which was great and
they sent them in a different
direction yes they did let's figure out
how that went down with zachary
they created an alternate timeline in
our first film in 2000 was that
just to because that they backed into
that
i mean i think it was to open up the
narrative possibilities of our of our
universe to set us apart from the
original series it's very producer of
your producers
give me an actor answer there's a bit of
backlash i will say
on the forums but uh but i feel like it
really
reset the clock so to speak uh
and it and it gave us a new point of
departure and a new springboard into
a whole other landscape of stories part
of the joy of star trek is the infinite
possibilities of
uh of storytelling you know um and so
i feel grateful to be a part of that
because we weren't hindered by anything
that happened before so charles what's
the difference between an alternative
universe and an alternative timeline ah
just semantics that's what i thought
usually when you think of alternate
timelines they kind of
converge back so you can have something
separate but then your returns
but really it could be an alternate
universe that goes off on its own
direction whatever
if that makes sense so for example not
really but okay
the mirror universe for example is an
alternate timeline right
where you have people that can interact
with our timeline and they come back and
forth alternate universe is something
that's so different that there's no
interaction
sometimes yeah but if you're splitting
into that that means you had access to
it well
there's the many worlds hypothesis of
quantum mechanics which suggests that
you can split into that and then no
longer have the possibility to interact
so do you think there are other versions
of us in another timeline well if we
think that the many worlds hypothesis of
quantum mechanics works
there are an infinite number or nearly
infinite number of each of us
in a completely different timeline so
there's an evil charles liu
and there's a great trumpet which one
did we get
which one do you want in the middle jack
that's cool that's uh that's very rick
and morty
when we come back uh third and final
segment of my interview with
zachary quinto on star talk
we're back on star talk featuring my
interview with zachary quito
the actor who portrays star trek
the entire target by zachary kinko
plays spock on star trek yes and
uh you know i had to ask him
about sort of
storytelling right and
but i had an issue with this sort of
reboot of the star trek series
and i had him there so why not why don't
i yeah
why not give him a smackdown get up in
his face
let's see what went down one of my
regrets was the original star trek
most of the time two-thirds of the time
they were morality tales
and i didn't see that as a mission
as a storytelling mission carried
forward oh
in our films yeah yeah just it's it's
more sort of a
big screen action entertainment
interesting um
which sells right it'll put people in a
seat but i wanted more
of the the oh that's holy wow that's a
mirror
to our own culture our own civilization
right
i think you know i think our culture is
a little bit less inclined
toward morality tales these days like we
want to escape
i can fully accept that i'm just an old
fellow a little bit i got
i'm okay with that oh that was no that
was pretty great
you totally you threw him a little i
think i did
you did you he was a little offended if
you listen to that he was like
oh i thought it was
crying no it was a kind acknowledging
but the point was
neil where you are is you're comparing a
tv
show with dozens of episodes right the
ability to take many
bites at the apple and feature films
which get one shot at entertaining and
putting people in the seats
so you said two-thirds of the show
where morality plays that means
one-third of them was pure escapism yeah
pretty much yeah so
you didn't give the feature film
enough credit he sounded like like like
he sounded exactly like
no no he sounded like he's actually
informed zachary on his answer
no zachary's answer was right we these
days may want more escapism in our
entertainment
than morality plays but in roddenberry's
day in the 60s if you watch shows like
bonanza
or you know wagon train they were all
one after another one morality play
after another
two-thirds of the time and then
one-third of the time was just escapism
with guns firing and horses running so
what should be the balance
depends on the medium you're working
with with a feature film
it might go with i i i i think rotten
berries
would have figured out a way to take
the morality play and put it in the the
the modern day star direct feature film
it's possible
i'm not sure and not to be heavy-handed
but i mean like for instance
what's his name that does the blue
people with the tails uh james
james cameron uh thanks
the guy who goes with the usb ponytail
avatar yes but if you look at that
there is there are several overarching
morality
um messages that are inculcated in that
film
you know one of which being that we only
get one planet okay
and we should take care of it another
being like hey man it's not
imperialism is not all that cool you
know there's several
i mean is this so wrong that i want to
have a better world i don't think he's
super heavy-handed with it either even
though some people would say he was he
was he whacked me over the head with
this well that's because you're a smart
person
but you know for for somebody who's not
like regular people
i i do not ascribe to that
distinction between quote regular
consumers and quote here's my point
that's i'm sorry i got to push back on
the seat you're the problem
you're the reason why we're in the mess
that we're in as this country
because we don't believe that there are
stupid people they're stupid people
damn it wait there are stupid people
that's right
chuck charles lou is to blame for that
because he doesn't recognize exactly
everyone else is stupider than he is yes
this is
his fault it's the smart people like
chuck lou who will not acknowledge that
there are a bunch of dumbasses out there
that makes it very difficult for us to
progress as a nation
i think we'll just have to agree to
disagree okay
[Laughter]
oh so here's my pushback you push back
i'm gonna push back too
no pushback is oh
i think if you're creative enough you
can fold
a dose you can apply a dose
of morality tail in your escapism
and end up accomplishing both or if you
do two of them you get
dose doses of morality too
chuck he needs more lessons from you
bring him to your you know
yes the best movies can do that can do
that but
those are not common okay and you got to
give the
the feature film genre a little bit of
credit and trying to do what it can do
the best it can
okay well zac so he also not only
rebooted spock yeah
he also rebooted the series in search of
oh dude
yes he did wait literally he's in search
of
yeah you know what the loch ness
monsters i remember is that the one that
leonard nimoy first did that yes right
and so now he so he's
following the ghost of leonard nimoy wow
he
is the reboot of the science series in
search of i asked him about it check it
out
wow in search of was a show that leonard
hosted in the late 70s and early 80s
um excuse me your first name basis yeah
well i have to say later
no you can say lettered i give you
permission i am now by proxy giving
permission
but um but uh he hosted this show in the
late 70s early 80s called in search of
and the original episodes were like in
search of
bigfoot or the loch ness monster or the
bermuda triangle
you know so they approached me about
redoing the show and hosting it and also
producing it
so we're keeping some of the hallmarks
like we did an episode on aliens
one of monsters of the deep but then
we're veering off into territory that i
find really compelling and interesting
like artificial intelligence
life after death and mind control um and
so it's been a real adventure i've been
all over the place i got to go to cern
in geneva hang out with your people
it's the biggest machine ever built ever
built by man on the planet i mean it's
amazing and to be in the presence of it
and to know that they had to build
something so gargantuan to look at
things that are so infinitesimally small
i found that paradox very humbling and
uh
talking to them was really interesting
and uh got to go to the green bank
observatory in west virginia and my
people they are your people man
so we've had a good time and we've got
good people you have great people
and really inspiring because you know
the thing that i've found
with ashoni i know you can relate to
this is the idea of people who are
devoting
the entirety of their vocational lives
to the exploration and discovery of
things that they may never
arrive at themselves and yet
the magnitude of it in service of
humanity
in generations to come is what motivates
them and drives them and there's
something so moving about it actually
and to meet these people who have been
working at the greenback observatory for
30 years
and know that they probably will never
find the thing they're looking for
hmm so he got into what my people do
yes yeah it's the quest
you have to at some level learn to love
the questions themselves yes
right learn to embrace the search
because it's the search
that is the task the discovery is what
the press talks about
once every 50 experiments that are
conducted
a quick thing about the green bank
telescope yeah that that zone is
a is a radio free zone correct it's like
because it's a radio telescope
they don't want like signals to be
messing up their signals so what do
people use
uh dixie cups to talk to each other what
are those lines huh land lines oh just
regular landlines
okay i forgot that so how about how far
away do you have to be
for i mean i don't remember the exact
number of kilometers but it's miles
yeah you got to go quite a ways yeah i
mean the green bank telescope the
itself right imagine a piece this is
green
west virginia yes there's a town and it
tells you it's named after that and and
this telescope named after senator
robert byrd
imagine a piece of metal mesh
that's the size of a football field that
you can move around and
aim at any spot in the sky that's cool
listen to signals
as if you were right there you know
trying to understand anything from you
you're loosely
using the word listen to yes because
it's still electromagnetic energy right
and you can turn it into an audio signal
on the other end but it's not sound it's
not sound i just want to make that clear
it's a signal coming through signal that
you detect
and then you can convert it into
something you can hear if you choose
that's right or you can make a visual
map
yeah and that's a picture right right
yeah and imagine using that technique to
listen to anything
from the pulsing of a spinning star to
these signals from an alien intelligence
all kinds of amazing so now
is that more effective or less effective
or does it make a difference
of an array like seti they do different
things
okay yeah they all have different uh
strong points and weaknesses
but this arrays are multiple telescopes
all moved in
synchrony right but the single steerable
dish is is a very very cool thing
okay a single stable disc can detect a
weaker signal
than an array that's it there's the the
point of the array
is to pretend you have a much bigger
telescope than you do right yeah so it's
a clever
backdoor way because you're not going to
have a telescope that large
that's steerable right so that's part of
the part of the the engineering
uh um
yeah one's a net the other's a giant
hook well said yeah yeah
yeah oh sure every once in a while chuck
with the metaphor
we need this guy
so uh do you have a favorite example of
what like a physicist might be looking
for
because they found the higgs boson
what's left wow dark matter and dark of
course dark matter
95 of the universe we don't know
anything about
except how it behaves on the largest
scales yeah there's
all kinds of needs yeah we're pretty
ignorant about that what is the most
effective means
of studying such a phenomenon
what effect they have on other things
that we can detect okay right and you
keep doing this
until you you oh it does this in that
condition let's write that down
and there's a boundary to it it does
this in that situation
write that down okay you keep doing this
and eventually
the elephant takes shape gotcha and
maybe you have an elephant
there but you don't know that if you're
only looking at little bits of it so all
the creativity in our field right now
is finding out other experiments that
you might conduct
on space probes on telescopes to try to
characterize
dark matter and then eventually you head
in the other direction
uh zachary mentioned cern right right
this big machine
uh what you do is the european center
for nuclear research
once you find enough barriers or
boundaries
to the thing like a higgs boson or
something then you take your machine and
you
look in that space where you think it's
bounded
to see if a particle like the higgs
boson exists and sure enough after years
it was found so what you're saying is
you look at all this hey something's
happening over here now focus down on
that
yeah well some interesting then focus
down on that right because you wouldn't
know to do that coming out of the box
you've got to work your way there right
so science is way more arduous
than it's ever captured in newspaper
articles that
only report on discoveries yes and yet
it is so much fun
isn't it yeah don't you think oh yeah i
mean as scientists we just
that's why we do it oh yeah it's yeah
it's the journey it really is
and if we get paid to do it that's even
better right oh not which
is whether or not i eat would you be a
scientist for free
yes but i'd much rather be saying like a
citizen scientist like
back in the day nobody paid anybody to
be a scientist but they did something
else and they did their science
no that's not how that worked back in
the day in almost every case
the people who had the luxury of being a
scientist they're wealthy anyway yeah
yeah yeah so if i were wealthy i would
still be able to do something they were
monks
they were provided for on a daily basis
didn't have much else to do like gregor
mendel for example who figured out some
genetics
so you're saying that most of the
scientists back in the day were just
bored
i would have been back then that's
something cool to study
that's right think about it it's great
yeah so it's quite a commitment to it's
a it's a devotion really it's probably
the best way to say it yeah right
so let me give you some we gotta land
this plane so what kind of final
thoughts do you have chuck
ah you know i'm just reflecting on on
storytelling aliens any part of what we
just went through in these three
segments you know i just think that the
power
of what we call science fiction
is ever growing in its
influence on society and i just hope
that it continues to inspire people
to be more involved in science because
that's the
great power that it possesses and i
don't think it's appreciated as much as
it should be i think we got the good
chuck yes
okay wait now let me let me give you
evil now
no that's that's the deadbeat
all right charles what do you have
zachary is yet another example of a
classically trained
thespian an actor who do shakespeare
then takes it to the next level to
science to science fiction
aliens but in the end he is still
illuminating the human condition for us
all bravo to zachary
okay i would say it's the job of
any fictional storytelling to illuminate
the human condition
or aspects of it what i like in
particular about
science fiction is that you get to
set storytelling on a
stage that you might think is
over there but in fact
it's right beneath your own feet so i
think science fiction gives you
wider birth to tell stories
that reflect back on your own condition
think of how many people wouldn't do it
if it was a lesson
against them telling them they're
misbehaving or telling them that their
ways
are are misguided nobody likes being
lectured too right
okay but if you said it on another oh
that's those are aliens doing that or
that's a
and then one day you wake up and said
they were talking about me the whole
time
damn eugene roddenberry
[Laughter]
so i think uh i think science fiction is
an important dimension not only for us
to figure out who we are
but also to give us a vision of a future
that we might one day embrace
and i will end with a quote from gene
roddenberry oh a paraphrase
who having written stories about
apocalyptic futures
was once confronted by a woman who said
why do you write about such
a a dismal future is this because that's
the
world you think we will have and he said
no
madam i write about apocalyptic futures
so you know
you need to avoid them
[Music]
very nice charles lew chuck nice yes
thank you for being in the house thank
you thank you thanks for watching
possibly listening to this episode of
star talk i've been your host neil
degrass tyson as always
bidding you to keep looking up
[Music]
you